the worst outbreak in years of toxic
algae known as red tide is killing
thousands of sea creatures in Southwest
Florida and harming the tourism business
red tide occurs naturally each year from
Sarasota to Marco Island it typically
lasts about six months this year's
season is in its ninth month and a
second toxic algae is coming from
polluted lakes like Lake Okeechobee some
80 miles away and is making the problem
worse Manuel Bojorquez is on Sanibel
Island Florida and well good morning
good morning you know the old saying
there's plenty of fish in the sea well
unfortunately here on Sanibel Island
there's plenty of dead ones along the
beach just take a look here the tide has
gone out and left behind thousands of
dead fish even this big eel this is a
stinky and unsightly mess this sandy
stretch of Florida's Gulf Coast may look
picturesque but beachside the view isn't
so pleasant
red tide is killing thousands of fish
eels and other sea creatures since
November some 400 critically endangered
sea turtles have died or been stranded
dr. Heather Baron at Sante bells crow
wildlife hospital is treating four times
the normal number of suspected red tide
cases this season it just can't even
describe what it's like to go out on the
beach to do a rescue and just City
surrounded by all these critically
endangered animals
red tide is a naturally occurring algae
that turns harmful in high
concentrations it usually forms ten to
forty miles out but winds and currents
can carry it on shore in humans red tide
may cause eye nose and throat irritation
coughing wheezing and shortness of
breath that's taking a bite out of
Quintus against Fort Myers Beach
business everybody's coughing
I work at a jet ski stand and I don't
get any business anymore man
have you ever seen it this bad no I've
seen some bad ones this is the worst
I've ever seen
Ossie Fischer is a second generation
charter boat captain it's hard to
breathe around it Oh stinks it really
stinks water is our lifeline here it
affects everything and if you lose this
there won't be anything here we are at
historic Lighthouse Point here on
Sanibel and typically this time of day
you've had loads of tourists out here
enjoying their coffee going out for a
morning stroll right now it's just a few
hardy souls tourism is a three billion
dollar a year industry in this county
the economic hit is not yet known but we
are told that some restaurants along the
beach in Fort Myers have temporarily
shut down out of concern for their
employees health Alex it's a sad sad
story thanks Manny